لذلك نحن الآن داخل المنطقة الخضراء ، فهذه
هي المنطقة التي كان يوجد بها جميع الدبلوماسيين
والمنظمات الدولية
، ومن الغريب القيادة عبرها
الآن خالية تمامًا باستثناء حراس طالبان ،
لذا فهذه هي
البوابات المؤدية إلى السفارة الأمريكية هنا في
كابول.  يخبرنا حراس طالبان
أنه لم يكن هناك أحد هنا منذ أن
غادرنا هذه السفارة بعد أيام قليلة
من تولي طالبان السلطة ،
لذا يمكنك أن ترى من هنا يبدو
أن هذا
نوع من الطبقة الأولى من الأمن
للوصول إلى السفارة والآن
حان  تم التخلي
تمامًا تمامًا كما رأيت هناك أن
المنطقة الخضراء تم التخلي عنها تمامًا
وهذا جزء من سبب
صعوبة قيامنا
بإجلاء ما يقرب من 100 أمريكي
بقوا على الأرض لأنه لا توجد
سفارة ولا يوجد أمريكي  بصمة
هنا سأقولها في شوارع كابول ،
تبدو الأشياء أكثر هدوءًا قليلاً ، فأنت
ترى النساء في الشوارع ترى عددًا أقل من
طالبان في الشوارع ولكن  حسنًا ،
هناك بعض المؤشرات المقلقة جدًا
على أن طالبان لم تغير
ألوانها الحقيقية خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ،
رأينا مشهدًا مروعًا في مدينة
حارة أربعة مختطفين قال طالبان
إنهم قتلوا ثم
تم تعليق جثثهم في الأماكن العامة على أنهم  نوع من
التحذير للأشخاص الآخرين للمواطنين العاديين
بأن هذه هي الطريقة التي
سيقدم بها طالبان للعدالة ، هذه
عدالة من العصور الوسطى للعديد من الناس في جميع
أنحاء العالم ، لكنها قد تكون نوعًا من
إشارة لما سيأتي وبالتأكيد
نحن نشهد  كما أن حقوق
المرأة خاضعة للإخضاع ، فالمرأة ليست جزءًا من
الحكومة الانتقالية ، حيث
لا يُسمح للمرأة بالذهاب إلى فتيات المدارس بعد
الصف السادس وما إلى ذلك وهكذا دواليك ،
على الرغم من أن حركة المرور قد تتدفق
بشكل مرصوف وقد أرتدي ملابس
فضفاضة قليلاً  وشاح الرأس
لا يزال هناك مستوى عالٍ جدًا من الخوف
هنا على الأرض من
أن الأمور ستأخذ منعطفًا ينذر بالسوء
عند لوريس ، وهذا أول
شيء ألاحظه هو أنك ترتدي
غطاء الرأس أكثر مرونة
الآن مما كان عليه في تلك الأيام المضطربة عندما
كان طالبان يتولى زمام الأمور ، هناك
مثال آخر على سيطرة طالبان
على إحدى الجامعات
هناك ،
صحيح أن المستشارة الجديدة
البالغة من العمر 34 عامًا ولديها
خبرة قليلة جدًا في التعليم لديها
قالت إن النساء محظورات بشكل أساسي
إلى أجل غير مسمى وأنه لن
يُسمح للنساء إما بالدراسة في هذه
الجامعة أو التدريس في هذه الجامعة
حتى
يتم إنشاء جو إسلامي مناسب وهذا نوع
مما قلته عن عودة الفتيات
إلى المدرسة أيضًا ولكن  لقد سمعنا هذا
من قبل من طالبان في التسعينيات من القرن الماضي
، تم إعطاء نفس العذر بأن
الفتيات والنساء يمكن أن يتعلمن
بمجرد إعداد نوع
المؤسسات لعودتهن ، لكن هذا لم
يحدث أبدًا الآن يقولون إنهم يريدون محاولة الاتصال
بك  تعرف على التعامل مع قضايا
النقل لضمان وصول النساء إلى
المدرسة بأمان لكننا قمنا بزيارة مدرسة البنات
بالأمس  فصل بالفعل ،
فلماذا على الأرض لا
تسمح للفتيات بالذهاب إلى مدرسة
تم فصلها بالفعل حيث لا يوجد
فتيان ، هذه هي أنواع الأسئلة
التي ترغب العديد من النساء خاصة هنا في
كابول في أن يجيب عليها الطالبان
وحتى الآن نحن لسنا كذلك  رؤية هذه
الإجابات وشيكة ، فإن طالبان تخفي
حقًا
ما
هي خططهم الحقيقية ، وذلك
لأنهم يائسون لرؤية
المساعدات الدولية غير مجمدة ، هذا البلد على
شفا كارثة اقتصادية حقيقية ،
لذا فهم يحاولون الآن
يقدمون أنفسهم على أنهم أكثر واقعية على
أمل إعادة فتح الخيوط الأولى ،
لكن الخوف بالطبع من الكثير هو
أنهم لم يتغيروا على الإطلاق